Est-ce que vous saviez que quand deux personnes du sexe opposé discutent ensemble,
il y a en général un mensonge toutes les trois interactions ?
Salut. Aujourd'hui, on est mercredi,
le jour des astuces et je vous donne des astuces sur les signes du mensonge.
Comment détecter un menteur ?
C'est la suite de la vidéo 90/366 que j'avais déjà fait sur ce sujet là.
Où l'on avait parler du regard,
de la direction des yeux,
et le fait de faire raconter l'histoire à l'endroit ou à l'envers.
Cinq astuces supplémentaires pour savoir que la personne ment.
S'il y a bien un signe qui ne trompe pas,
c'est la distance que peut prendre la personne avec les faits.
Difficile à comprendre dit comme ça.
Mais très facile à comprendre si je vous parle de Bill Clinton à l'époque de l'affaire Monica Lewinsky.
Il avait déclaré :
"Je n'ai pas eu de relation avec cette femme".
C'est clairement une prise de distance.
Au lieu de dire "avec cette femme",
il aurait du dire "Je n'ai pas eu de relation avec Monica Lewinsky".
Mais le fait de simplement la globaliser dans un groupe :
"avec cette femme",
est un signe typique du mensonge.
Ces signes doivent être cumulés entre eux pour avoir la preuve formelle ou le sentiment formel
que l'autre ment.
Il peut il y en avoir un ou deux dans une discussion de vérité.
Mais quand ils sont trop nombreux à apparaître,
alors là, il n'y a plus de doute.
Un autre signe, c'est la personne qui répète systématiquement la question.
Ce n'est pas parce qu'elle a mal entendu.
Ce n'est pas pour préciser votre question.
C'est simplement pour gagner du temps.
Un menteur ne peut pas répondre spontanément, à la vitesse normale d'une conversation normale.
Il doit gagner quelques précieuses secondes pour préparer son argumentaire
pour préparer son mensonge.
Dans une conversation normale, ça peut arriver qu'on mette beaucoup de temps à répondre.
Parce qu'on a vraiment besoin d'une réflexion derrière ça.
Pour se rappeler un souvenir
ou pour avoir un avis concret et construit.
Un menteur a à peu près le même delta de réponse.
C'est-à-dire pas spontané,
pas immédiat
mais pas très long non plus.
Troisième signe du mensonge : le trop de détails inutiles.
À ne pas confondre avec les bavards qui souvent racontent une histoire
dans l'histoire
pour revenir au point de départ.
Mais le menteur, lui, pour crédibiliser le fait que l'histoire
ou son mensonge ait vraiment eu lieu,
va rajouter pleins de détails précis, trop précis
trop nombreux,
beaucoup trop nombreux !
Quand on parle, c'est qu'on a toujours un but,
quelque chose à dire.
Le menteur, lui, donne pleins de détails
pour donner pleins de matières
à son histoire qui sort de nul part.
Son premier but c'est de la rendre crédible avant d'avoir quelque chose de réel à dire.
Quatrième point, c'est l'utilisation répétée et quasi systématique
des phrases restrictives.
Les phrases et les expressions restrictives se mettent plutôt en début de phrase.
Comme "Pour dire vrai ...",
ou "Pour te dire la vérité ...",
ou "Pour être très franc avec toi ...",
ou "Pour être vraiment être honnête ..."
ou "Je te jure que ...".
Elles servent à appuyer la véracité d'un propos
alors que vous n'avez pas encore tenu ce propos.
mais vous admettez que potentiellement la personne pourrait en douter.
Naturellement, on utilise des phrases restrictives quand il nous ait arrivé un truc vraiment fou.
Une histoire insolite où on se dit "personne va me croire".
Mais quand ces phrases là sont utilisées quasi systématiquement
pour des choses très banales,
alors attention !
Vous pouvez avoir un doute !
Et le cinquième point, c'est une analyse que vous pouvez faire très simplement,
très facilement,
c'est la cohérence entre les versions
et la cohérence directe.
Plus la personne va raconter son histoire,
plus vous allez pouvoir voir des différences entre les versions.
Ça c'est le premier point, c'est très facile à voir !
Mais vous pouvez avoir l'esprit critique sur la cohérence directe.
Soit, entre l'histoire et qui est la personne.
À titre d'exemple, les réactions que dit avoir eu la personne dans l'histoire qu'elle vous raconte.
Est-ce qu'elles sont assez crédibles ?
Est-ce qu'elles correspondent à ce que vous connaissez de cette personne ?
Est-ce que vous l'avez déjà vu réagir comme ça ?
Est-ce que vous l'imaginez comme ça ?
Bien souvent, quand c'est un mensonge, non.
Parce que c'est trop ou pas assez
ou trop différent de la personne.
Idem pour la cohérence directe de l'histoire.
Parfois, dans l'histoire qu'on vous raconte,
il y a une vraie grosse incohérence.
Une vraie incohérence de logique.
Entre le début de l'action, ce qu'il s'est passé et la fin de l'action.
C'est quelque chose que vous n'auriez pas fait comme ça,
que personne n'aurait fait comme ça.
Ça peut être aussi de la cohérence temporelle :
les dates et les lieux ne peuvent pas correspondre à tout ce qui a été raconté.
Après, c'est à vous de voir !
Ou vous vous décidez de piéger la personne en lui demandant des précisions
sur les points incohérents.
Ou vous laissez couler
et vous essayez d'associer ça à d'autres signes du mensonge,
pour déterminer si c'est un mensonge ou pas.
Encore une fois, rappelez-vous, il faut prendre en compte tout le contexte
et voir si il y a plusieurs signes qui vous permettent de déduire que c'est un mensonge.
C'est la deuxième vidéo sur le sujet.
J'aimerais vous en faire une troisième qui parlerait plus du langage corporel lié au mensonge
avec les lapsus emblématiques, les illustrants.
Si vous êtes plutôt chauds pour qu'on aborde ce sujet,
vous me le dites dans les commentaires et on verra.
Je le passerais peut-être en master class.
Soit avant mi-juillet,
soit début septembre.
Seulement si ça vous branche.
Vendredi, je vais mentaliser l'un ou l'une d'entre vous !
On l'a déjà fait dans deux vidéos précédentes.
J'appelle l'un d'entre vous par Skype et j'essaye de le mentaliser.
Je vais tourner cette vidéo demain.
Donc aujourd'hui, à 17h, sur mon Facebook,
au moment où sort cette vidéo, je vais créer un poste
pour que vous puissiez participer ou essayiez de participer.
Il suffira de liker et de mettre un commentaire dedans.
Tout ça donc sur la fanpage sur Facebook.
Vous avez le lien dans le descriptif.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu.
Je vous prépare un truc aussi pour la semaine prochaine pour fêter les 30 000.
On vient de les passer !
Avant de partir, n'oubliez pas de laisser un sincère et sympathique
pouce en l'air !
Et de vous abonnez à la chaîne en cliquant sur le logo ou sur "s'abonner" juste en dessous.
Puisque le MentalVlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an,
depuis le 1er janvier.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h !
CIAO !